hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round four of the 2019
single Kappa we didn't show any games
from round three I decided to show a
game 11 of the Capablanca saga instead
as all of the games like we mentioned
ended in a draw but here's a very
exciting game from Round four Fabiano
Caruana versus LaVon Oregon and it's
gonna be a very exciting line of the
Berlin defence so without further ado
let's just check it out we have E 4 by
Fabi ePHI by 11 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to b5 sorry about that
Bishop to b5 the reuleaux pieces on the
board will Knight to f6 the Berlin
defence and now d3 with Bishop to c5 and
now c3
Korona prepares d4 with castles by 11
castles by Caruana and now rook to e8
and here with d4 just pushing the bishop
back with Bishop to b6 and now there are
a few games here that have rigid
disposition rook to e1 is a normal here
Bishop to g5 is a known move here but as
far we pretty much on every move chose a
very rare continuation now with the b5
already on move eight we enter a
never-before-seen position of the Berlin
defense
so we have a completely new game you
can't go to a5 well do two before just
losing a knight so you have to go to e7
with Knight to e7 but I don't think this
really came as a surprise to Levin as
you kind of don't go into this if you
don't know what you're doing so far B
grabs the pawn with Knight capture Sonny
511 captures the e4 pawn and now Queen
to f3 attacking the knight on e4 11
brings it back with Knight to f6 and now
d6 by Caruana
very exciting so what what can black
play here Levin decides to capture the
pawn with pawn captures on d6 and now
Knight to c4 attacking the bishop and
also preparing to recapture on d6 and
here while xi could decide to just
continue developing bring the knight
over to c6 or to g6 he instead decides
the for the moment at least hold on to
his
extra porn so the five attacking the
night and c4 and now Knight to d6 and
this night is now well officially a
monster night until black finds figures
out a way how to kick it away from there
you were attacking the rook you have to
move the rook also this Knight moves the
f7 point is quite vulnerable so rookie
fate taking care of both threats and
here Bishop to g5 already threatening to
create some weaknesses on the Kings side
xi decides that it's time to give back
the pawn and just you know get a get rid
of all of this tension
well nicely for now giving back the the
pawn with Knight captures pawn captures
Queen captures and now you could play
rook to e8 to defend your knight but
would rook to e8 to the Queen just moves
and the night still remains spin so just
f6 getting rid of the pesky bishop with
Russia back to e3 and now d5 finally
freeing that isolated D pawn queen back
to f3 and now Knight to g6 now by
playing f6 11 also created a very nice
outpost for his knight on e5 with Knight
to a3 Bobby now perhaps can play Knight
C to D for maybe block the isolated pawn
and then attack it later with Bishop to
c7 transferring the bishop on this nicer
diagonal and now rook a to d1 piling up
on the on the isolated D pawn with nice
to e five attacking the Queen you can't
really stand the king side as blacks
bishops are just too powerful so we have
Queen to e2 and now a six pushing the
bishop back push up to a4 and now Bishop
to g4 attacking the Queen and the rook
so you have to play f3 here with f3 and
I'll brush it back to e6 finally
defending the d5 pawn with Bishop to b3
now with a double attack against the
pawn here and now rook to e8 and here F
for a very nice idea for example if
black decides to go Knight g4 then you
just move the bishop and black has no
useful discoveries we'll have to make
use of this both rook and the Queen
being on the e-file so after f4 with
Knight to c6 bring the
my back and now comes Queen to f3
getting out of the e-file now with a
triple attack
well not that but with a triple attack
against the b5 point and it's not not
good to defend it for example if 97 just
c4 so here Bishop back to b6 putting
pressure on the e3 pawn also if the
lights progress remove removes the rook
will also be attacking it Knights the c2
adding another defender to the bishop
and the now comes Knight to a5 and here
favi has to decide whether he grabs the
pawn or he goes for Bishop captures and
b6 if he goes into this line where he
trades everything followed by Queen f2
captures captures and now Knight to c4
he will have to give up his light square
bishop and thus fix black's pawn
structure and he will not be grabbing
any pawns
so for example Bishop captures pawn
captures and black's pawn structure is
now fixed on the other hand if you play
Bishop captures on b5 which is what Fabi
played you just win a pawn so we have
Bishop captures on b5 Bishop captures
rook captures on d5 and now Bishop
captures on e3 with Czech Knight doctors
and III and now Queen to b6 just the
pinning the attacked piece the night on
e 3r up the d3 defending and now Knight
to c4 with a nice triple attack against
the night here and now if you play rook
e1 then you allow black to go in for all
the trades a knight captures rook
captures and then you could either trade
or go ro k e8 Bobby decides for a
different line after this Knight to c4
move he doesn't defend the Knight Rider
Queen to d5 check will pick up the night
11 didn't want or a piece of course you
will win back the e3 night
so King to f8 you don't want to go to 88
as you will have to I deal with a lot of
a lot of back ranked weaknesses so Kings
the f8 and now Queen captures on c4 11
wins back at the night immediately rook
captures and e3 route captures and Queen
captures with check King h1 and now rook
to d8 so here we have a queen and rook
and game where Khurana is up upon his he
has an extra seat bone our black
have any see pawns with h3 our fabric
creates some breathing room for the king
and now b5 pushing the Queen back with
Queen to c6 going after the a6 pawn and
out Queen to e2 going after the rook and
also the b2 pawn rook f3 with ideas of
going maybe Queen c7 fold where g3 to
threaten the g7 pawn but first 11 says
it's time to win back some material with
Queen captures on b2 Queen captures on
a6
karana also wins the a pawns now his
again up upon and now h5 preparing h4 to
prevent a rook to g3 we have king to h2
Bobby also doesn't want his King and on
the background constantly have to keep
checking for any checks and now age 4
just preventing that rook to g3 idea
we have Quinta a7 and now comes King to
g8 tucking the King into a safer Square
Queen to e7 attacking the rook and now
of course Queen to d2 just defending the
rook with rook to e3 11 now controls the
D file Fabi controls the e-file and we
have Queen to d6 offering a trade of
Queens and if you play captures captures
then black can hold this position to a
draw even being down a pawn so after
Queen d6 we have Queen to e4 Queen back
to the 5 again 11 all wants to go into a
king and rook endgame Queen to b4 we
have rook to c8 now trying to pile up on
the on the backward C pawn and here
Fabi played a 4 and I don't know if it's
this position exactly but it's one of
the positions around here maybe a few
moves back that level was so low on the
clock
that he pressed the clock while he had
one second on the clock and then ok he
was rewarded increment but he almost
lost in time so not sure if this is the
exact position but somewhere around here
and hereafter a 411 played Queen to c5
just you know with ideas of trading
Queens as the Queen is under attack
also the rook is under attack so you
cannot push something like a 5 here as
you lose the rook
but this doesn't work here so feel free
to pause the video here and figure out
why this doesn't work and find the
winning idea
for Caruana in this position well I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent finder of winning
moves and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
rook to e8 check it's a pretty
remarkable 411 to miss a move like this
but like I said he was very very long
time and probably even in this position
he had maybe only a few seconds on the
clock and it's easy to miss an idea like
this
so obviously you cannot capture the rook
if you capture lose the Queen
that's just lost so after Luke e8 check
11 played King to h7 but now comes of
course rook captures and c8 you have to
recapture the rook Queen captures and
now a captures and b5 and now all of a
sudden we're 11th b-pawn was controlling
fabi's upon in C pawn now
Fabi has two connected passports on the
Queen side and whereas 11 has no
connected passports on the Queen side
and this is just unplayable 11 of course
tried to create some chances with queen
a queen a 5 B 6 Bobby just continues
pushing his past pawn queen to d3 hoping
for B 7 if b 7 and 23 allows xi to draw
by repetition like this just Queen g3
Queen Queen e1 but of course Bobby
played C for a crucial move now the
Queen guards the d1 square so no Queen
g3 t1 action is possible we have Queen
to g3 check King each one and now Queen
to d3
I don't think Queen to d3 actually comes
with any any sort of a threat maybe hope
hoping for Queen f1 check fallback Queen
captures on f4 but Fabi says no it's not
a problem he just pushes c5 and it was
in this position that 11 are in and
resigned the game as after Queen f1
check the Queen now also guards the f4
pawn so even that is without a question
yeah really really exciting him
especially as it comes from the Berlin
but so many interesting games arrived
from the Berlin recently that you know a
you know a few years ago everyone
thought that if it's a brilliant it's
gonna be super boring but you know a
sensor everyone saw how alpha zero
treats the Berlin you know and even
before that it became quite quite an
exotic
opening Kramnik versus Aragon for
example in Oregon versus chronic for
example in the candidates for crowning
just unleashed the the brilliant theory
was a really really awesome but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Peter Burgess for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the sinful
cup containing the Capablanca saga and
of course checking up on your
suggestions and I didn't show the
standings as so far only Anand and Fabi
won one game all of the other games were
drawn in all four rounds so it's a bit
of a slow event but maybe maybe you know
things will brighten up so thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day